Now you've got these two evil creatures
here at Fox and the cat.
I think this one's based on one of the
Marx brothers,
actually Harpo Marx,
who I believe,
never said anything but be that as it
may,
there are these Ne'er do well characters
on the Fox in particular.
Now Fox is a standard trickster animal,
right?
It's a,
it's a,
it's,
it's a classic animal.
Maybe because it's,
it's good at hiding and it's good at
hunting.
I don't know exactly why,
but it's an coyotes are like that too.
They're classic trickster animals.
Um,
he's Kinda like Wiley Coyote,
in fact,
you know,
the,
the warner brothers character who's a
genius at large and of course whose
arrogance continually gets him walloped
and this character has a lot of features
like that,
but he,
he's,
he feigns being,
uh,
an English gentleman of like the 18
nineties and pretends to be educated
and,
uh,
it has our kind of high blown way of
talking and he's a fraud through and
through.
And he's got,
he's got this,
you know,
sidekick who is barely there at all and
he,
he doesn't treat him that well,
but he's got someone to Lord it over.
So that keeps his dominance hierarchy
thing going well.
And the fact that he's like a second
rate companion while he never really
noticed is that although he'll treat
them contemptuously whenever he gets the
chats.
So anyways,
they're walking down the street and uh,
the,
uh,
Fox is bragging about some crooked thing
that he's done and how he pulled the
wool over someone's eyes.
And he confuses that with a wisdom and
intelligence.
And one of the things that you see this
is worth knowing too,
because if you're preyed upon by a
psychopath,
which you will be to some degree at some
point in your life,
the psychopath who will be narcissistic
will presume that you're stupid and,
and,
and that you deserve to be taken
advantage of because you're naive and
stupid.
So it's actually a good thing that he's
doing it.
And,
uh,
he,
his proof for,
and I'm saying he because there are more
male psychopaths,
um,
the,
uh,
the proof that you're stupid naive is
that he can take advantage of you.
And so like if you were wiser you,
you'd be,
you know,
you'd,
you'd know his tricks and then it
wouldn't be morally necessary for him to
show you just exactly who knows what
about what.
And so the psychopath will use his
ability to fool you as proof of his own
grandiose,
grandiose omnipotence,
omniscience and narcissism.
And the problem with that is that you
can be fooled by a psychopath and
virtually anybody can.
So that Robert Hare,
for example,
who studied psychopaths for a long time
and interviewed a lot of them,
like hundreds of them and videotape many
of the interviews he said when he was
talking to the psychopath,
he always believed what they were
saying.
And then he'd watched the video
afterwards and see where the
conversation went off the rails.
But you know,
the pro,
the proclivity to be polite in a
conversation is very.
And if you're polite,
you don't object to the way that the
person unfolds their strategy,
you know,
and psychopaths are pretty good at
figuring out how to manipulate obviously
how to manipulate people and the
probability that you will be immune to
that is extraordinarily low.
Go Watch Paul Bernardo being interviewed
by policemen on,
on Youtube.
That's bloody,
that's enlightening man.
Paul Bernardo,
he's like the CEO of a meeting in that
video,
you know,
it gives the cops hell.
It gives the lawyers hell protested his
innocence.
He basically tells them that they're
rude and untrustworthy because they
don't trust him because he did a few
little things 17 years ago and he gets
away with it.
A few little things,
right?
I mean,
he killed a bunch of people,
including the sister of his girlfriend
at the time and you know,
he was a repeat sexual offender and
murderer.
It's.
But he basically goes,
well,
you know,
that's a long time ago.
It's like we're,
we're past that,
aren't we?
I mean,
I'm having a discussion with you.
I'm trying to solve help you solve some
crimes,
which by the way I committed,
but we won't bring that up,
you know,
and you're,
you're,
you're accusing me of being a liar,
like you're not playing fair,
what's up with you?
And then when they answer,
he looks at his fingernails,
which is like,
that's a lovely little manipulative
thing because it basically means
whatever happens to be under my
fingernail at the moment is much higher
priority than listening to your foolish
story and you watch,
you'll see people do that to you and
then you get a little insight into what
they're up to.
He's very good at that.
And so,
or he looks outside or are you just
looked at his hands and he looks out the
window immediately.
Dismissive in his nonverbal behavior.
It's brilliant that the courts were
forced to release that by the way,
but look it up,
Paul Bernardo on Youtube.
Wow.
It's,
it's just mind boggling.
he's so good at what he does and he's
good looking and he's charismatic and
you know,
he can really pull it off and you can't
tell what's happening with the cops.
And the lawyers,
whether they're just letting them play
as a routine to get some information
from him or whether he's actually
setting them back on his heels.
And I suspect it's a bit of both,
but it's a masterful performance.
If you didn't know who he was and you
were watching it without the audio,
you'd think he's the CEO of some company
given its employees hell for not being
up to scratch.
That's all his body language,
his eye contact,
everything just speaks that it's
amazing.